So here we are. Welcome to another Zoom call. We'll get started with this. I never wondered why
the verses, so many verses, if we talk about God will uphold us with with his right hand.
Interesting side note of that. I teach course on covenant theology. You made covenant with your
right hand when people tribes would make covenant with one another. That's why we still shake right
handedly. We shake hands. All comes back to how tribes used to make covenant. So this is how
God taught us the human beings to make covenant. You actually made a cut in your right hand.
You bled both parties would make cuts in their right hands and you'd grasp hands together.
But thereby, Miggly, your blood say that we are now blood brothers. So it was by your right hand
that you made covenant. So actually what it talks about scripture that God will uphold us with his
right hand. Talks about his covenantal hand that he's with. He's promising to uphold his
covenant through his son Jesus Christ with us and that's what our hope is is in that covenantal
relationship that we have through his son Jesus Christ. Interesting side note there. Okay, let's move on.
If you have not been on the member site, we have really good news. We are now offering going back
to offering one-on-one calls the way that we're able to kind of get around that. So first of all,
when state board came after us and multiple other doctors, I didn't ask you a few weeks would
have been prayed for Scott Jensen. He's a Minnesota doctor who who ran for governor under the
Republican ticket and lost to walls, Tim Walls who was the existing governor in Minnesota who
and long story short, Dr. Jensen is a practicing medical doctor in northern Minnesota
throughout the whole process that they have been weaponizing the state board to come after him
politically. So they've used the state board as a political weapon against their
their adversary, their quote-unquote enemy in the Republican party, which I think is just absolutely
don't write criminal. So be prayed for him because they are going to use us the after heaven source
Ellis our secretary of state. So when the board came after us last
June and file a lawsuit against us, if you haven't we've talked about this multiple times,
they filed, they sent all these things against us. We had to take down our number, our
tons of stuff on our website and clean up our website. And the bottom line was they couldn't prove
anything and we ended up there in a copy that's basically settling the whole suit with just
requiring us to put on that little stipulation on the bottom of our website that
we don't practice in Minnesota, which was so ridiculous because anybody who became a member and
became a patient of ours had to fill out the whole PMN agreement, which went 100 times beyond that
little stupid little paragraph. So that was their compromise, which was 100 times less than what we
already did, which is just absolute foolish political nonsense. But we can go back to one-on-one
calls if we're calling them educational calls, not telemedicine visits and you agree to terms
on the form that you have to complete. So you just have to complete the form you'll see on the member's
site. This box educational coaching calls not a telemedicine visit and it explains a little bit
here and you have to click on this thing right here coaching call request form similar to the
cheek swap request form. It actually helps save you some time on that you know in your calls that
you could kind of preempt me for the visit. So I know what you want to talk about. It will save us
maybe a few minutes on the call. So it'll save you some money in time. And then you can also pay for
the call right there too. That saves us staff wise having to submit that. So now if you just
fill out that form and you agree to the terms that it's not a coaching that it's not a telemedicine
visit but not practicing medicine and you agree to the terms you agreed to watch more surgeon terms
where you signed up for our whole thing here. So yay yippee woohoo excited you'll have actually
these calls. And quite honestly this was a spiritual battle for me as well. They came after me and
basically you know threatened you know to throw me a jail for doing what we're doing you know I had
to come down to yeah we and there's things that we had to clean up in our office there's things that
we needed to protect ourselves with and I think we made those changes and God uses
adversarial situations to help us grow and change and mold us and shapes us to be better witnesses
for him. But in my prayer time last week I was just really convicted about I'm supposed to be doing
what God has called me to do regardless of the circumstances and whether they decide to throw me
a jail or not I'm going to continue to do what God has called me to do and be a faithful witness
so going back to these telemedicine visits not telemedicine visits these coaching call visits that
are not telemedicine visits and we want to help as many people as we can so just you'll see this form
on there just click on this on the it's on multiple pages on the member site and you can just call
and talk to the reader and you whoever answers and schedule that as well. Reminder that you have access
to all our courses we're going to have a new autoimmune disease course up here in a few weeks
really that's going to be a great informational course too so
and you have the full all our blog posts remember on our members make sure you search for those too
okay some questions how often can you take the right programs that get rid of parasites how often
can you use the right programs that get rid of parasites um so the parasite programs like the
all bugs kill program and some of the other very specific parasite programs there's you can you
can literally run those 24 seven if you wanted to not suggesting you do that because um you you want
to be running your cancer programs but parasites don't have what you have to be careful with with
other programs um there's really only the the certain bacterial programs that will cause
curbside burn reactions and and that I would say it's not wise to do too much of those those are
typically lying with programs so lying in the Borrelia, Borrelia, Bacteria, Bacteria is a
gram-negative bacteria that has lipopolysaccharides in the cell membranes and if you kill
uh gram-negative bacteria too quickly you will liberate a lot of lipopolysaccharides and are
the most stimulated immune system reaction that if you have an autoimmune disease can make
can really cause a flare we don't deal with that with cancer patients so that's not what we're talking
about but cancer patients but also have live disease and if you're going to run a lot of live programs
you could curbside or give yourself a hurt three action which is not what you want to do you will
not do that when you run parasite programs that will not happen when you run cancer program so
you've been running those as often as you want I need to search on hammerball and variants and also
jack hammer amplifier on item I saw when looking over the true right website okay about empty so two
questions one I know the hammerball was intended as a sleeping partner that you get right next to
which I do nightly and what distance is it so weak that it's of no real benefit so if you're using
the the ball without the jack hammer amplifier it can be about three feet away from you and still
have some benefit of course the farther you move away from you the less benefit so that's why I
tell you to snuggle with the ball but if you have the habit of the thing falling on the floor you're
really restless at night or the thing ends up feeding four or five six feet away from you everything
when boarding with you wake up then getting the jack hammer amplifier would be a wise thing to do because
that really pushes it out a number of other feet so I've said multiple times the jack hammer amplifier
really isn't necessary for most our patients unless you're gonna do it during the day since I
tell people to snuggle with the ball but we have some patients that just can't snuggle with the ball
and they get the amplifier so that they could put the ball under their bed now we said
all our patients and are you know with the jack hammer amplifier comes with it but anybody that's
purchased a right from us or the plan from us you know prior to two weeks ago then you didn't
get it in unit to purchase it separately from true right so but I still I personally don't use it
because I have the ball right next to me and I really doesn't go anywhere so it's still snuggling
it's right up next to my body when I wake up in the morning so but if you wake up in the morning it's
four feet away from you and it could have been like that all night then getting the jack hammer may
be the other thing to do to get so number two is the jack hammer something I should look into
with those circumstances available and yes does it extend the range yes it extends as the range
does it boost power well it just extends in the range so you yes you have more amplification
um so but if the ball is right next to you without the jack hammer it's still going to go through you
so you know if you if you have the habit of sleeping right next to it and you always use it with it
right next to it that you don't need the jack hammer but if you use your right but different times
where the ball is two three four feet away from you then get the jack here I'll make a video about
this and put it up on the site too what do you think about using ivermectin as a cancer
preventative well there are studies that are out there that ivermectin has helped people with cancer so
that is another protocol that you could use you could get ivermectin and take it as a cancer treatment
as a cancer preventative well what is preventing cancer well you're trying to get if you're truly
preventing um cells from uptaking toxins that can damage the DNA that it's just trying to live
the best lifestyle you can so that you're not exposed to as many toxins but the truth is it's literally
impossible to not be exposed to toxins so um if you're talking if you if you're defining prevention as
that you'd ever get a diagnosis of cancer because it's helping your body kill it prior to it ever
getting to the size that it will ever be diagnosed and i'd say yes could be a preventative so is
you know taking medicinal mushrooms not having cancer i'm taking you know you take mushrooms
anyhow you know you take immune stimulants and you know aloevia immune product and you know
probably saccharides and you know curcumin and other good products so that you don't get cancer
you you're taking it so you can kill it before it ever becomes cancer too so you're doing you are
doing that as well so yes i think that would be something to take i don't personally know a number of
people that take i've erected literally daily or they they um more people that pulse it they might take
it three days a week and and you know they're not taking you know just to tell you they're not taking
a prescription they're taking over the counter buy it at fleet farm typeplaces the
pace for horses um and uh they have swored by it for years that really helped them through
COVID and um they literally there's there's uh different pages that you can get on different groups
that you can get on that there's thousands and thousands of people in the group that are doing this
so um there's no side effects to them so you're taking a very low dose
nitric oxide question doctor bush a doctor macola have exercises that i think are supposed to
increase nitric oxide they take four minutes to do and are supposed to you're supposed to do them three
times a day i've been doing that for over a year and feel a year and a half and i feel good when i do
also the biologic dentist i'm seeing one that's great to take a supplement called
neal 40 which is a nitric oxide boosting supplement i read somewhere that nitric oxide isn't good for
people with cancer had a small breast cancer tumor removed last april ago but i still have
circulated to ourselves in my body are these exercises good to do um how about a nitric oxide supplement
yeah not now is there any time they would be okay or good to take how do i know
so nitric oxide is um a phenomenal is a nutrient that your body actually will make
and it's the nutrient that you take it in a lot of things too it's partly through the
gluteilin pathway nitric oxide functions in um largely in the endothelium so the endothelial
layer is the layer of epithelial cells that line with the revascular system all your arteries are made
up of the interior lighting it is called the endothelium and it's a single cell layer of epithelial
right underneath that endothelial layer is smooth muscle layer and that smooth muscle layer is controlled
by neurologically through the sympathetic and parasympathetic nervous system so it is uh
autonomic nervous system controlled that's what controls your blood vessels you don't think
all contract with blood vessels and they contract or relax by blood vessels and they relax if
they're autonomic through the autonomic nervous system that's sympathetic and parasympathetic control
and then there are tons of different receptors on those muscle layer cells that um will
uptake nitric oxide and other things that will cause relaxation by thereby dilulation and constriction
um of those muscles thereby constricting the blood vessels and thereby increase your blood pressure
so if you have high blood pressure um taking nitric oxide supplementation and I think there's a
lot better supplementation than the deal 40 um that's what I did that right now but um uh
you somebody with high blood pressure should strongly consider nitric oxide supplementation
now the problem with that with cancer is that nitric oxide also stimulates a wonderful thing
called vascular endothelial growth factor which is which is how you make new blood vessels
and what you want if you have a history of cardiovascular disease any type of cardio problems
you want an uptick in in a vascular endothelial growth factor because you could actually create you grow
what are called an astymol seed vessels that help feed the heart and other tissues and uh
and nitric oxide like I said will will relax the smooth muscles
and cause dilation of vessels thereby decreasing blood pressure
so a great thing right yeah but the problem is if you have if you have a growing cancer especially
and we're not talking about blood cancer we're talking about hard cancers here so not not
leukemia but a lymphoma yes and any other regular cancers that we're talking about if you have a
mass of any kind and you increase your nitric oxide production you are going to increase your
vascular endothelial growth factor long story short you do not want to increase vascular endothelial
growth factor if you have a hard tumor because you will increase the growth of blood vessels into
the tumor but thereby feeding the tumor better and thereby causing the tumor to grow
so the standard rule is you know you're basically training cardiovascular disease patients
and and um cancer patients
oppositely you know very differently um um especially if they have a mass so let's say
you know this case this person this question said I had a small breast cancer removed I still
understand I have surgery tumor cells in my body so yeah so you don't have a tumor right now
could you do nitric oxide exercises for for sure could you take even a nitric oxide supplement
I would say no and less you have any signs of high blood pressure because if you have normal or even
low blood pressure and you take nitric oxide supplements that could be a problem too so you could have too
much relaxation um endothelial smooth muscle and you could you could cause diseases and all sorts of
things too so that's not a good thing remember everything your body's well balanced but if I had a
mass in my breast that was you know palpable and I'm still dealing with it there's no way I would
touch any nitric oxide supplements whatsoever nor would I take nitric oxide nor would I do
nitric oxide exercises um so if I have you know pancreatic cancer I have colon cancer if I have
the breast cancer or any any no mass whatsoever in my body that was cancerous you do not do any
nitric oxide your increasing vascular endothelial growth factor you're gonna worsen your problem
by big time it could cause growth so don't do that but remember anything you read about your
eliciting to things this is great you're learning things you know nitric oxide you get talk to
somebody um I think it was doctor Nathan says last that's his last name um uh wrote a book on nitric
oxide of course you write a book on it and that's the world's best for everything you gotta understand
a balance of everything right so nitric oxide your body does make it you do get it in your diet you get
it in your in that's that's why we tell people not to eat kale shakes if you have cancer because it's
the highest in nitric oxide you're nitric oxide and greatly be vegetables so it's good you need that
balance but you don't want an abundance of it with any type of cancer with my last cheek swab results
you said to reminder of no dairy I do not uh do dairy accept allowed organic butter should I be
decreasing or eliminating this as well no you're fine if you're having a little bit of organic butter
every day we're eating a stick of butter every day that's a problem but put a little
an organic butter on something that's just fine you're okay I'm gonna be meeting two different
breast surgeons in the coming weeks and want to be prepared with good questions I want to avoid
problems or complications later if I do have surgery I don't know what to look out for or what to
request so that I may be discerning and choose the right person or team any advice um that's really
hard you have to just feel comfortable with your surgeon surgeon number one so I always suggest that
you do have a meeting or two with that with him or her and that you feel comfortable you should be
praying about that and just get asked that God gives you discernment in this there are any really
specific questions that I can dig up or things to look for in that it's really whether they're you know
they're hopeful and they're they're and you feel like they're honest with you you know you don't
want to do surgery just because that's the thing that they do at this point you want to do surgery
because it's the right thing for you and you want a surgeon that thinks that too so that they look
at your case and look at your CT scanner MRI or anything and they say yeah I think this is what
we're gonna do I think this is gonna be really good and ask you know there's nothing wrong with asking
what would you do if this was your sister you know what would you do if this is who your wife
for your your friend your best friend could you please be just honest with me and ask of that question
please really be honest with me um and see if you get a heartfelt honest answer from them so that's
what I would do and just send you a cheek swab I forgot to mention we did go to a biological dentist
because one of my causes of my initial cheek swab was dental I haven't a dental worked out in my life
except for a couple of pull baby teeth and wisdom teeth the biological dentist did a panoramic CT
and said he did not see any indications of infections or anything wrong so is there anything I could
be missing as far as dental cause no so the cause if the cause was dental it could have been
15 years ago there was an infection and because of the great things that because I know who wrote
this the great things that you've done over the years you killed it and you're doing great so
that's that you know you did the right thing this is the right thing to do with your biological dentist
if they didn't see any any infection any underlying infection then you're good to go
so you're you're perfectly on the right track uh I have metastatic breast cancer to the bones
in January February went off all my meds my alkaline phosphatase this is a liver function test
but remember alkaline phosphatase also um we'll go off if there's if there's
bony destruction so if there's bony destruction for metastatic cancer to the bone which
are very said multiple times that that almost all metastatic cancer to the bone is
lytic in nature mediates destroyed bone and alkaline phosphatase will rise so this is a good this
is a good marker to use for if there's any increase in bony destruction so this went down so that's
really good so my calcium went from 9 to 9.3 but that's not much that's not enough of a difference
to say that there's lab error there so I would say that's really the same um uh so you're still
with a normal range there so that's fine your ast went from 22 to 36 that really ast really has nothing
to do with bony destruction um uh so ast has to do with uh it's a liver enzyme has to do with
some liver function or there's there's um it could be simply because detoxing the different
meds that's literally what it could be for metastatic cancer there's lots of different things that could
rot that could cause that rise but even at that I would be concerned and since you're uh you're
going to take you're going to do these the blood work monthly let's just keep an eye on it and
again with all blood work whenever you're looking for patterns so um what is the pattern how does it
change um is it going in the right directions or is it going in the wrong directions over time say
that's good okay some questions like Karen are you familiar at all with the whole food supplement brand
standard process yes very familiar standard process I used to sell all of standard process supplements
that was a very big end to standard process um until I had a confrontation with them uh in the
confrontation was that standard process opened up their own online store um and their own amazon store
and then they stocked any any practitioners that were selling online because they cut off our
company so I thought that was I thought it was very unethical of them as a company and and why and
that that practitioners like me are what built their company um by talking up their products to our
patients and for them to to basically undercut their practitioners by selling their own products online
was just to me that was just so unbelievably unethical we can we can sell standard process again
because my daughter is a prep actor and works in our clinic but I choose not to because of that it
just to me that just was just really hard for me to to to they just I they're continued their unethical
I don't know who holds the company now but they continue their unethical practical practice because
I just heard last month that they fired a rep that was with them 20 years because he built up two
big of a business and they wanted to take over that clientele he had a multiple employees for
I just have some I just don't like companies that do business in a in that kind of way so
they have great products don't give you wrong we just don't sell anyone so we have a lot of people
have taken their products and I'm not talking about them to bash their products I've never ever said
one negative thing about standard process after my staff um but this is first time I have somebody
asked a question hi is Icelandic cod liver wild caught in can okay to eat once or twice a week uh yes
I'd say yes um you can eat that you can buy wild caught salmon you know um lots of places
even by our local grocery store um in Minnesota it's come foods they have wild caught salmon that's
frozen that's actually fairly inexpensive um compared to other you know could went to hold food
or something like that um but yeah I know you could get you know there are as there's argument
that when you have canned foods you could get heavy metals or a little bit of it I have never seen
the studies on what she if they're already in this particular product and maybe you could google it
if I don't um but you could probably make a argument that there's heavy metals and just put
everything that we that's why you're not feeling stuff so if you don't absorb these heavy metals
in the foods that we eat but um yeah I would say anything with an eraser is fine I mean
waking up at 2 a.m. and my heart is beating more and I can't get back to sleep what can I do about
that I'm not eating after 6 p.m. thank you okay so if you wake up at 2 a.m. every night what could
that be a symptom of well there's a lot of things but um there's this hormone in your body
that your adrenalin makes called cortisol so cortisol is released at times of stress
so if you're driving down the road and you're at police siren behind you and you feel like your blood
pressure just went up your face just kind of flushed a little bit because you got a little scared
but they might have been after you and then they zoomed by you you're like woo that is a release of cortisol
among other things there's some evident for it really stall so cortisol um increases your blood
pressure so cortisol contracts your arteries it increases your blood pressure because it's a good
thing to have your blood pressure released if you have to run away from a polar bear so um at times
of stress you sometimes need to flee so you need an increase in blood pressure to pump blood to
your extremities and feed oxygen to the muscles so that you can run away so there's
purpose of that song remember every day is a balance that's not a bad thing um so cortisol is also
released to the circadian rhythm in order for you to release um your glycogen stores in your liver so
glucose you eat glucose you eat food you eat carbohydrates that break down the glucose and the glucose
excess glucose is stored in your liver as a long chain sugar called glycogen and glycogen then
is released at times you need it like at times of fasting um you release that glycogen stores in your
liver um you're ready to 10k you need glycogen stores you know at the three mile mark you have used all
the glucose search later in your blood to contract those muscles now you need glycogen stores in your
liver so you'll release those glycogen stores in your liver you also need glycogen in glucose
in your brain at night so your muscles might not be using a lot of glucose but your brain
uses glucose the main food for your brain is oxygen and glucose and if you don't have glucose for
your brain your brain is going to suffer so you will release glycogen stores in your liver at night
and you do so by having a circadian rhythm eating a rhythmic release of cortisol in the middle of the
night so um that's what could be happening the problem is is that if you don't have that rhythmic
so so the argument here is okay wake up 2 a.m. with my heart beating more so that the heart beating
more is a side of increase cortisol um but i can't get back to sleep that's a side of decrease cortisol
so i know it's really confusing that i don't want to harp on this too long but you need that circadian
rhythm release of cortisol to release glycogen to keep your brain alive at night if you have a
decrease of that so in the effect of adrenal insufficiency you won't get that circadian release of
cortisol and you will wake up at night in order to kick in your adrenals so that you release cortisol and
that your brain stays alive and those are the people that i wake up every night between one and three
o'clock and i can't get back to sleep but it takes me a long time to get back to sleep those people have
adrenal insufficiency therefore they have to wake up their body their brain wakes them up
in order to get cortisol released through a different pathway not the circadian rhythm pathway but
getting awake having to wake up getting agitated getting up having to walk to the kitchen get a
drink of water and that's how you're releasing cortisol so the treatment for this is typically you
start by eating some protein before you go to bed eat some protein before you go to bed see if
that helps fix it number two start taking some adaptogens to stimulate and support your adrenal gland
and then those don't work then let me know by the next zoom call certain amino acids like glycine and
methyl B vitamins are needed in order for the body to detoxify since i have to be a low animal
protein and have no methyl groups also i have a when the person said i am MTHFR that means they have
MTHFR a genetic defect methyl tetrahedral a reductase gene defect it seems i am not able to detox the
way i should can i use some kind of amino supplement to help with this yes you can use protein supplements
that's why we have a protein powder through us enzymes that's low in blue to me that we recommend
that you feel like you're low in amino acids should i do a cheek swab to know a little bit more of what
by B vitamins you can but you could start simply with trying with the us enzymes protein
and see if that makes a difference with you and again with cancer patients the only
cancer patients that i recommend go on a methyl supplement ventilated supplements are those that
maybe have high full-mesistine levels so getting a blood test and getting your whole-mesistine levels
checked it'd be a good thing to do you said protein zym is good it contains kale is that a problem no
it doesn't contain too high level so it's not a problem so it's okay remember you're you're not
you're not gonna ever eliminate you know nitric oxide sources in foods i mean i want you to eat
green leafy vegetables and you're eating some spinach but i just don't want you to have a kale shake
i am generally very good at taking my supplements in a timely fashion but occasionally i get to 4 pm
and realize that i'm not taken by earlier supplements when this happens is this better just to skip
what i forgot back on schedule or should i try to cradle them all into the evening i would say skip
i would say skip um and just take your night supplements you'd be fine i asked last week but did not
write down the video was not there but i do write during the day also and use to amplify the jack
camera module um as i'm not always sitting do i need to use the ground event no you don't you don't
need to use the ground event with the jackhammer the only thing is by if you use the jackhammer it
increases the amplification and if you have it right up if you have the bulb right up to your tummy you
are gonna have you're going to basically putting a charge on your skin like if you if you walked around
in a in a dry house on the carpet or your socks and you dragged your feet and then you go touch
a balloon and you get a shock right that is just an electrostatic charge on your skin of electrons
because you are rubbing your feet on the floor and you're picking up you're producing an electric
that electron charge you can also do that with the right machine you're picking up electrons
those are good things okay but it's not feel good when somebody comes and discharges it on you
and touches you and you both get a shock doesn't feel good so they're wrong with it it's just that
using a ground event can help ground that if you want it to don't need to use a ground event i never
suggest using that you have to use a ground event when you're using the balls so yes it works just
as well without it really doesn't work it doesn't make it work any better i have short day
programm only one hour programs two of them you can use those use after everything is iv vitamin c
a good thing for anyone with cancer or or do or should some not do it what about some of the stage
for a very cancer now with a remission so no i would not say vitamin iv vitamin c is good for anyone
with cancer nothing is good for anyone with cancer well i guess i can argue that sometimes you
probably would be good but the negatives thing about iv vitamin c is that just because you have cancer
doesn't mean that you don't have something else going on it just about everybody on this planet
now has an autoimmune disease so if you also have an autoimmune disease let's say let's say I'm
thyroid Hashimoto's okay so you know you've been doing all these nutrients to stimulate your immune
system and stuff and vitamin c is a very strong immune system stimulator say let's say if you didn't
have cancer and you have Hashimoto's and you somebody talked to it to do it iv vitamin c pretty
much guarantee you are going to get worse your thyroid is going to get worse you're going to have a
greater attack on your thyroid you're going to have a lot of tiredness issues with your thyroid you might
want to get a blood test in your t3 and t4 away off i can't figure it out i hadn't balanced for a
long period of time why is this kind of flaring up again and you're going to have issues because you're
doing a really strong immune stimulation that's why it can be really good with cancer but it can be
really bad with autoimmune disease so if you're in remission and let's say let's let's say because I
don't know your situation let's say iv vitamin c help get you there maybe going down to maybe
once a month to do it would be a fine thing to do um but if you're in remission and you it wasn't
iv vitamin c that got you there i wouldn't start it um and that would be would no matter what kind
of cancer you have is desiccated liver recommended so desiccated liver if i didn't recommend it for you
and i know you don't i didn't recommend it for you but is desiccated liver a good thing for people to
take sure it's great as long as you have a good source and almost all any good good supplement
company is using a New Zealand uh liver source uh where you know it's much less adulterated uh food
sources for the animals and you've got a good clean liver source so yes desiccated liver can help
stimulate liver function a desiccated organ can help stimulate any any that organ issue and um we're
you know i wrote article on using desiccated organ supplementation specifically for autoimmune
diseases because there's a philosophy out there that you know since you have anybody's to
sell tissue let's say it was thyroid like kosher rotos like the example i just said and then you
take desiccated thyroid it can help that immune reaction that you would have against your thyroid
actually take place against that desiccated tissue that you're concerned so we didn't
calms your thyroid itself down so it can be very helpful but desiccated tissue organ tissue is also
been very helpful to help replenish the basically hidden under nutrients of that organ to help
rejuvenate that organ so it can be very beneficial i was made in cod liver oil and it's all not
the cod fish oh god yeah so yeah you're fine i don't that cod liver oh yes for sure yes i noticed a
shock on my computer without the grounding that yeah there's nothing wrong with that so
the reference to the daily right can i also use the night time programs during the day absolutely yep
we have a lot of people that actually do that so they we have a number of people at work at home
and they run their night programs at night obviously and then during the day they'll set up
their right where they're by their computer whatever they're working at home and they run the day
program all day long you know so or the night program all day long so that's just starting to
so it's easiest yes to do let's say it's Wednesday you're gonna run the Wednesday night program
during the day and Wednesday and at night when you go to bed it's just easy to remember that way
so you're just doubling that program that day so that's that's just fine yes
and what my cancer was when i was really doing very poorly i would run it i was literally
well i wasn't running the right 24-70 so i wasn't running in the car but i was running it
constantly through the day and obviously when i got home sat down i was running the right
still through that so where i sat down at night i'd be running the right so um the more right time
you could get the better it's gonna be so remember you know what you're doing with the right
is you're hitting that cancer to get your immune system to take another and another and another
and another and another and another and another and another and look at it so we'll start attacking
and killing it so the more right time the better the reason it's feeling good that you get outside and
do something but if you're sitting at home watching tv or reading a book or
relaxing you want to be racing okay if you enjoyed this late
we are now offering one-on-one calls again um you just have to complete that form and agree with
to the stipulations that stay forward put on us i guess but um and uh so we're really excited about
that god just opened up the door for us to do that again and um we are thankful for that um
um and you know we have some new people here uh they'll call too we had a um just um uh just
clinics like ours have been attacked over the years and our turn was well we got attacked back
in the early 2000s for doing the rife um but that was by the the car project board came after
super hard i got dragged in front of them about 12 times i hated what i was doing
finally my attorney said you know i told you the story lots of times but
the attorney said you don't even practice that practice but the other car practice
is just practice under your pastoral medicine license and just pull full blow and take care of
cancer patients so that's what we did and then the state um uh attorney general's office came
against us i'm in 2012 because we were helping this young girl with uh
regimental blastoma which was a brain cancer uh she came to us and she was doing the rife and
doing nutrition and she was just doing fantastic absolutely zero side of cancer
and the oncologist said children's business of Minnesota patient um file the complaint against us
because the parents didn't want to do chemotherapy and so the parents just asked why i don't know if
we want to do chemotherapy i don't know why we have to do chemotherapy you know she's got no
side of disease for your MRI when she drove home uh the mother and father drove home with the daughter
when they got home there was a sheriff at the door say that you will do chemotherapy or we're taking
her away from you and she will go in the foster care and do chemotherapy then we're taking her older
sister away from you because we're gonna have you declared as a comfort parents and instead the
maternity general's office came against us too because we were her we were her alternative practitioner
she was also going to do an active puncture and also going to a psychologist because this kid was
traumatized well it went to court and we basically won and the judge did say well i do i don't have enough
evidence to say that you she could get out into a chemotherapy but i'm really in favor of the
alternative doctors here and they forced the state that actually the county Hennepin County they forced
Hennepin County to pay for all of our care all of her acupuncturist care and all of her psychologist
care and they forced the oncologist to do monthly calls with all of us at a group call and explain
what care that he was recommending for this young patient usage it was it was unbelievable huge
with that that god prevailed with with that um so that was that was really really cool um and the
the state really left us alone until last year um when they just came against us again and it wasn't
just us because i actually personally don't multiple medical doctors or the state of Minnesota when
that got the exact same letters and um and they just in January dropped everything against us
as well as we put that little stupid stipulation on our website that we don't practice medicine
which was like i said one tenth on the stipulation that we have that everybody signs when they come
on board like that so it was a really ridiculous but again showing that god's right hand
were uphold us you know we stay close to him we trust him um
that that god can't take things away from us too but god does allow what he wants to allow and we
have to just trust him that he is he is he is righteous and he is sovered and all things and he knows
what's best for us and um he allows difficulties to come in our life to mold us and shape us and
grow us more towards the image of his son and that's what our goal is that's what our life's
goal is really that's what it should be we're reminded of that every day so with that uh
know that i love you and i pray it for all of you make sure you um get your questions in on the
the member site make use of the member site and um as much as you possibly can and again schedule one
of the ones if you need to just call the office the way i love you and pray for you all and i'll talk to you
that's going to bye bye